YEN-JIE LEE: So
during class, I like
to take a few minutes of break.
So that will allow
the students to take
some rest, because usually
the content is so intense,
such that people--
it takes some time
for the students
to actually digest,
and then to understand,
the concepts covered in the
first part of the lecture.
And also, it give
them an opportunity
to interact with me.
And usually, during
the break, they
bring a lot of questions, which
I didn't anticipate before.
There are many, many
questions about mathematics
and those of physics concepts.
Here you have del
square e, right?
And the del square, you have
1, 2, 3, turn, three operators.
And while you are--
if you write everything
explicitly-- so basically,
this operator is going to be
operating on ex, ey, and zz.
And then, we can usually
solve them during the class.
And I can even cover part
of the question asked
during the break, so
that everybody, actually,
can benefit from those
interesting questions
people actually bring
up during the break.